il est évident que le cadre légal des
jeux d'argent crée
en soi-même des tensions et le rôle du
régulateur et de rester sur la ligne de
crête et de faire en sorte que ce qui
est par principe interdit peu par
dérogation être autorisé c'est ça je
dirais le cœur du cadre non mais c'est
le principe et ça n'est autorisé qu'à
une condition c'est que le jeu d'argent
reste récréatif le pacte social
collectif qui a été formé dans ce cadre
légal par ce cadre légal c'est de dire
donc font le jeu d'argent est toléré et
ça ça existe je dirais de longue date à
condition qu'il reste récréatif
aujourd'hui on voit que cette notion de
jeu récréatif c'est une notion qui est
quand même fragilisée par les pratiques
parce que cet écosystème industriel qui
s'est mis en place effectivement
attendant sa industrialiser le jeu
d'argent et de à le rendre de moins en
moins récréatif est-ce que pour autant
c'est impossible de garder cet équilibre
moi je ne le crois pas je crois que
d'ailleurs dans tous les pays on est
confronté à la même situation la France
d'ailleurs n'est pas le pays qui est le
plus en difficulté sur ces enjeux
pourquoi parce que des pays comme la
Grande-Bretagne qui ont libéralisé
beaucoup plus que nous se trouvent
confrontés à un retour de situation
catastrophique d'un certain nombre de
joueurs d'opinions publiques extrêmement
négatifs sur le jeu d'argent alors que
nous nous avons eu une croissance qui
était beaucoup plus
contrôlée du jeu d'argent donc ma
réponse en deux terres en deux temps un
le régulateur
doit mobiliser tous les outils qui sont
les siens et nous avons je crois fait
cet exercice
et on pourra le démontrer en 2023 et 2
il faudra se livrer et c'est l'objectif
que nous avons à partir du mois de mai à
un bilan critique de la régulation en se
disant est-ce que dans le fond ces
outils d'intervention sont suffisants ou
est-ce qu'il faut par exemple sur la
publicité donner les moyens au
régulateur de plafonner les budgets
marketing ce qui n'est pas le cas avoir
la possibilité de restreindre les
horaires de diffusion de la publicité
limiter la publicité des jeux d'argent à
certains supports qui sont des supports
professionnels mais pas les supports
grand public il y a toute une série
d'idées qui nous viennent d'ailleurs de
nos homologues que nous pourrions tout à
fait pratiquer en France
pour faire en sorte que ce jeu d'argent
reste dans son épure récréative